- We don't know exactly
what these ivory manikins were used for
but we know about 100 of them
still exist in the world.
Many of them were made
in the late 17th century.
And, most of them are female.
I'm Anne Garner, Curator of
Rare Books and Manuscripts
at the New York Academy of
Medicine here in New York City.
Today, we're gonna look
at some 17th century
ivory, anatomical manikins
that show the secrets
of the human body.
There's something very
powerful about handling
these objects partly because
they're so mysterious.
What we think is that they
were probably collected
as status symbols by male physicians.
There's at least one account of a woman
who was walked through the
stages of her pregnancy
using one of these manikins.
If you lift up her torso,
immediately you see what's inside.
Here we have her abdominal
wall as one layer.
Then we're down to her
intestines which also come off.
And behind the intestines
is the real money shot.
You have a fetus.
And, all of these manikins that we know of
that are female are pregnant.
There's something that feels devotional
about the way that they're positioned.
They all feel very precious
and almost like votive offerings to me.
And, by appointment,
you can come visit these
and see for yourselves
how delightful they are.